yeah the zombie thing i was like eating
guts and everything oh nice
nice okay i'm also gonna try not to make
a sex joke about you
what sex joke would you just make well
you're talking about eating
guts
well you're related to
i'm sure you like
eating
eating what
you eat out wait vagina this is
like if i was eating it's a stretch of
what i'm going yeah if i was like
a successful lesbian just just stop
hello guys i'm ryan wright and i'm
ariana bossary we've been asked by many
to check out from top fives a video that
is not a top five video actually it's
called the russian sleep experiment the
most terrifying human experiment ever
performed it's a top documentary six and
a half seven minutes seven minutes seven
minutes of watching us watching a video
this is called entertaining my attention
span is like four minutes
[Music]
the russian sleep experiment is the
terrifying tale in which five people are
kept awake for 15 days and the
horrifying effect it had on their minds
and bodies
now this is just a story and there is no
evidence to prove this actually happened
but with that in mind people say with
the things that were going on in this
time period there is a possibility
something like this could have been
conducted
because we cannot forget that in the
same area as this story is based russian
scientists released a video of severed
dog heads that were kept alive for
several hours using an artificial blood
circulation system
so although this is fictional there is a
possibility it's based on historical
experiments so let's get into the story
although this is not real it's true it
could be really in russia decided to
conduct experiments to test the effects
of extreme sleep deprivation
they selected five world war ii
political prisoners deemed as enemies of
the state and promised them freedom if
they could stay awake for 30 days 30 now
they were then sealed into a small
chamber and exposed to an experimental
gas stimulant to keep them awake jesus
the prisoners were monitored through
portholes and microphones and they were
provided with enough food to last for a
month along with some books running
water a toilet and beds
for the first five days very little
happened apart from the discussions
between the prisoners were getting more
emotional and they started to reveal
their inner thoughts to each other
on day six their behavior took a turn
for the worst they were getting paranoid
stopped communicating and started
blaming each other for being trapped in
the room
they started sitting with their backs to
each other and strange inaudible
whispers could be heard through the
microphones
after nine days one of the men started
screaming he ran up and down the small
chamber in crazed terror screaming and
crying so much that he lost his voice
and reduced it to a whimpering croak
it was later discovered that he had
completely torn his vocal cords
the four other captives seemed oblivious
to the screaming man but two of them
were observed quietly tearing pages from
books defecating on them and sticking
them to the glass porthole in the
chamber
by day 14 the scientists could no longer
look in and observe the subjects
on day 15 the screaming had stopped and
the room was silent it was only the
oxygen monitors that indicated any sign
of life and no longer able to see in the
chamber the scientists were concerned
the men had fallen unconscious
at midnight on the 15th day they decided
to open the chamber to check but before
opening it they sent this message to the
men
we are opening the chamber to test the
microphones step away from the door and
lie flat on the floor or you will be
shot compliance will earn one of you
freedom
the cell remained silent until one
quivering voice said we no longer want
to be free
the scientists entered the cell and were
greeted by a vision of unimaginable
horror the food provided was not eaten
but the men had blood dripping from
their mouths
each of them had chunks of flesh and
sinew ripped from their bodies and there
were indications from the destruction of
flesh and exposed bones on their
fingertips that these horrific wounds
had been self-inflicted not by teeth but
by the subject's bare hands
themselves
some of them had so much flesh stripped
from their bodies that their rib cage
could clearly be seen and their internal
organs that were still attached and
working had been removed from the body
cavity
the subjects were still and silent but
when the scientists turned off the gas
it sent them into a frenzy they attacked
the scientists and guards with such
strength that one of the security guards
who tried to stop the attacks died after
having his testicles ripped out with the
bare hands of one of the subjects along
with this five guards were also killed
all efforts to sedate the five men were
resisted it was as if their bodies were
rejecting any drugs that tried to pacify
them
even after receiving a dose that would
normally have put down three men it
failed to calm the subjects
in the frenzied violence that followed
two of the subjects succumbed to their
horrific self-inflicted wounds
finally the three remaining men were
restrained and tied up all three of them
were begging to be kept awake refusing
anesthetic and choosing to have their
surgical procedures to have their
removed organs placed back in their
bodies whilst wide awake and without
painkillers
the first subject to be operated on died
due to blood loss and it was discovered
that nine bones in his body had been
broken
the second man who had started screaming
on day six of course unable to speak
communicated by smiling as surgery was
performed in a seemingly sick satisfying
way
when the surgery ended he became angry
and demanded by writing on paper that
the surgeon should keep cutting
the third subject simply muttered over
and over i must remain awake
although distressed at the monsters they
had created the scientists were still
intrigued by their subject's behavior
and decided to return the two surviving
men to the chamber exposing them once
again to the gas
only one made it back to the chamber
though the other fell asleep and passed
away
the final surviving subject grew
impatient demanding he be returned to
the chamber immediately he broke free
from his restraint and grabbed one of
the guarding soldiers guns shooting two
of the scientists in the head he was
overpowered and before more damage could
be done one of the scientists grabbed
the gun and pointed it at the subject
he shouted
what are you i must know
the subject replied have you forgotten
so easily we are you we are the madness
that lurks within you all begging to be
free at every moment in your deepest
animal mind we are what you hide from in
your beds every night we are what you
sedate into silence and paralysis when
you go to the nocturnal haven we cannot
tread
the scientist staggered backwards before
shooting the subject as he lied dying on
the floor he spluttered his last words
so nearly free
so that is the russian sleep experiment
like i said this is just a fictional
story but it's possible that it could
have been influenced by historical
events there is no denying that if a
country could find a way of keeping
soldiers awake for long periods of time
this would greatly increase their
fighting abilities and things like the
stanford prison experiment the nazi
experiments and the cia's mk ultra mind
control prove psychological experiments
on humans similar to this have happened
so i hope you've enjoyed this video and
next week's special will be the story
behind the amateur horror thanks for
watching and don't forget the importance
of a good night's sleep
i have never wanted to sleep so bad
before that's in
what is that word there's a word for it
where you want to keep yourself in
captivity because you
no i don't know it's when you like your
when someone steals you and you like the
person who put you in the position
stockholm syndrome
google
what's up google what
that's how i remember that wouldn't have
bothered me the whole time
okay so this is a made-up story but
there's historical [ __ ] that could be
like where it was all inspired it
happened and they did weird stuff to
dogs so why wouldn't they i wonder why
like
by them staying awake if how that would
affect them and meaning like cause i
i've tried staying awake for like two
days in a row but i just want to sleep
why
because i would i i don't know i was
young okay
i think it's crazy that the point of it
was to see how how they could improve as
soldiers that's insane they they were
just so [ __ ] like i mean if you're
not sleeping i totally can see how your
mind starts to go a little crazy after
like staying
almost away for just two days and that
was it yeah so i'm delusional yes
i can only imagine that but but yeah
it's like it shows like physically to
how much rest your body needs
they ripped out a guy's balls yeah they
were clawing off their own they died
everyone died yeah but then that's what
they learned from this
the people in captivity died maybe a
great way to torture someone like if
someone really wronged me
just keep them awake yeah like they're
like the other day there was this guy
who oh my god he he had the nerve to
double dip his french fry in my ketchup
is he your friend
yeah known for like 15 years all right
jerry oh i know jerry yeah i swear to
god i think you would keep him awake i
will keep
i'm sorry do you think i'm being out of
line yeah
then i need to reconsider my values yeah
um i don't love it but
things that bother me more
perhaps you always get another ketchup
the severed doghead stuff that actually
creeped me out a lot more
than the human stuff because i'm like
they said the dogs were still awake they
were able to stay alive with the blood
is that possible i don't know
we should try that i have two cats [ __ ]
that
[ __ ] that and [ __ ] you and [ __ ] your
goddamn channel i'm leaving
on [ __ ] believable end of the [ __ ]
video i gotta plug myself before
no that's like everyone says like in a
movie you watch a human die and you're
like all right and then you see a dog
you're like no
animals are these innocent pure
yeah like dogs are just pure love and
loyalty god
then [ __ ] with dogs don't [ __ ] with dogs
but i gotta say if they're able to like
keep me alive when i'm older by
decapitating me and just like hooking up
blood [ __ ]
wait hold on arianna
hold on okay
i would like that
thank you i'm so glad you finished that
statement you just be like a talking
head you definitely could not talk yeah
but i could still do rap
you oh okay please forgive me you may
not be able to speak but rap stays
forever
the fact that these guys are eating
their own flesh
shows how much well you can't say the
fact
that let's just put that up theory of
them
like clawing away their own flesh but
they don't want to be asleep and they
don't want to die yeah that's the crazy
i imagine that you would start getting
so delusional that you would think you
don't need sleep then you don't want to
go to sleep i noticed that at least for
me in order for me to sleep i have to
also want to go to sleep but if i don't
want to go to sleep i can't just sleep
so i feel like when you get that
delusional you'll go like oh i don't
need sleep at all like i don't need to
they were [ __ ] insane and all they
wanted was their freedom that'd be a
cool movie i would watch a movie about
this hollywood if you're watching
make a movie about this and i will start
it i wanna play one of the russian
scientists
scientist
you're going to die from never sleeping
you dumb [ __ ]
communism
i'm so glad i'm so glad i was here for
that yeah
hey come on man this was in world war ii
yeah oh come on we're not playing this
you're jewish you this is your time to
get sympathy
i'm not trying to get sympathy
are you sure you're jewish
i'm sorry
i couldn't go a video without a jewish
joke could i it's not my full identity
either this is my mom it's like just
jewish ah racist jokes that are at an
appropriate video anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it you can subscribe today and become
a rejectionitist a rejectingitis i don't
know why i keep going with that people
are people like reject or reject the bot
okay but rejected nidis sounds like a
something you go to the doctor for yeah
it's for when your anal anus tears a
little bit
you've got to get your anus stitched
together better to reject the night out
yeah they go like
ryan wright gave me rejectionitis you
would oh yeah tear that out okay you can
check out ariana bossary's channel get
bossa reed
[Music]
devin wendler can i get a shout out my
dick is like i want to see devin all
right devon let's see how i want to see
the type of guy who posts on someone's
comments just to say their dick is like
oh this is you evan wendler okay dude
you're saying you're addicted i know how
old he is
first listen dude you look really young
so i can't really make no a long dick
joke along with you because that
lawsuit so we're not gonna do line is
legality we're not gonna do that i will
say though when you are 18
hit me up with this comment again it
might be 18. when you're 18
maybe i'll consider looking
but not at this age
it's illegal
you want to look at it no
when he's 18 i might take an interest
maybe if you're lucky
that's okay to say it's okay to say
right i'm technically okay to say that
right i don't know i'm not like an
expert i'm talking about when he's 18.
reject the bots you decide
end of video